das war auch schon her dass im
extremsport ja ist doch so manchmal darf
ich eigentlich beim anfang gar nicht bei
dir das sei nicht warum hast du das mit
du rein kommst du sollst den coolen
effekt hat vielleicht die anderen machen
hey leute was wir doch jetzt bekommen
beim neuen video beim neuen video
hey leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
jetzt macht man jetzt einmal applaus für
den star marie aber bis 90 nein du bist
nur gast heute auf mein fahrrad muss
egal das nehme ich so gut gemacht leute
was geht ab märz will kommt zu einer ach
so das ist ja schon gesagt heute leider
wieder ohne jugend es immer und wir
haben uns für heute was sehr sehr
interessant uns überlegt und ich habe
jetzt anstrengen deswegen wurde ich
gleich auch noch ganz kurz war machen
für dich wird es eigentlich glaube ich
nicht so anstrengend für mich weil ihr
fällt gleich was ich meine
und zwar habe ich ja diese reihe
gestartet ich teste virale tik tok live
max und ich habe gestern ein kommentar
gesehen dass ich doch mal virale kassel
kickbox also so kannst du weißt du wo
man so kunststücke macht versuchen
erstmal dachte ich okay nein das ist
nichts für mich dann habe ich mir ein
paar angeguckt und dachte okay das
könnte ganz lustig werden auch wenn es
nicht klappt natürlich versuchen wir das
alles funktioniert so wie es halt auch
in rom gehen soll
die you got talent haben wir schon mal
die jugend macht mit seiner ex freundin
gewalt und da kommt man schon mal
durcheinander lesbar ist auf jeden fall
wird ist ich kann dir mal zeigen um was
es geht ich habe vier oder fünf
herausgesucht und die versuchen wir ganz
einfach vor dieser kamera nachzustellen
ich weiß nicht ich glaube wir müssen
immer ein bisschen weiter nach hinten
gehen so wird man alles sieht okay und
euch wenn ich das tik tok natürlich
immer hier ein komm mal her
ich zeige dir jetzt mal dass erst dann
kann es ja mal sagen was du davon hält
dass ich meine legistische angezogen
habe natürlich gibt es für mich
anstrenge als für dich sein warum ich
muss sich noch halten hier und ich muss
hier mit die komplette körper sondern
halten
ich kann es jetzt nochmal kurz zeigen
was wir können ja mal das erst kurz
versuchen dass sich nämlich auch nur
gebacken und dann musst du nicht dass
ich dich so irgendwie machen das kriege
ich hin aber wenn du mir sicher und dann
musst du ja durchaus weiter gedreht so
dass ich muss ich für fragwürdig 150
kilogramm wiegen
was hat es jetzt richtig gefragt nur
sein okay das ist einfach das erste
versuchen kurs ja so und jetzt wichtig
nach vorn
wichtig sei hier um
[Musik]
nur das ist was los also wie soll ihre
anstrengungen aber kriegt man muss das
gerät bekommen
ich hab's verständnis während du deine
hässliche durch noch nicht die heute
darunter ja genau
ja aber das ist noch mal gut läuft aber
nicht mit nicht mit der händel anderem
vertrauen
[Musik]
wer jetzt die rente glaubt mir ich weiß
gar nicht ob noch nicht wirklich sieht
das ist echt schwierig wie heute wir
haben es uns gerade angeguckt ich glaube
wir belassen es dabei
ich weiß nicht das dumme ist halt ein
poster auch durchmachen müssen
ich glaube da braucht man auch richtig
körperspannung führen wir erste den
fußball auch durchmachen müssen ja
während meine hände hält und dann sind
da ja das problem ist dass wenn ich als
ich ihr die hände geben wollte werde ich
pastinaken geflogen gut weil ich glaube
dass ich dir sagen noch ans linken weißt
du große mann soll das mädchen
wahrscheinlich keiner ist naiv
wahrscheinlich größer ist ich bin halt
ein ich bin 90 194 können nur 191 ja
okay leute egal kommen wir zum nächsten
das wird jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen
einfacher
[Musik]
ich hab mir dass ich weiß wie es geht
weiß ich noch mal kurz die kamera ein
bisschen weiter runter gehen wir schon
mal auf dem boden
so machen wir so eine brücke zur
entscheidung das ist jetzt nämlich
normalerweise ist das hier bei mir
machen aber ich muss jetzt bei dir
machen war ja auch so im video zu fahren
so kannst du dich hier halten
ja aber jetzt muss ich mich nicht zu
sehr
[Musik]
er warte man aber haben wir da jetzt
irgendwas vergessen
nein schon richtig so blind dass du
[Musik]
nicht das recht übrig willst du noch
nicht zurück war allein meine hände
natürlich was war oder hände des
highlander zeigt er auf den fall dass
der 2009 weiter runter weil ich habe
dort das gewicht das gleiche
ja bist du ja nicht was machst du da ja
egal dass die erdbeeren sich für nichts
erspart sich genau mein krebs erregend
ein stetiges video jetzt dann kann ich
okay leute was auf das nächste mal für
dich eigentlich okay leute hast du auf
das nächste das ist um so einen trick
halt was man hier zeigt sie jetzt konnte
ich mich ganz normal hochheben und jetzt
musst du dann deine hand hier unter mein
kind und dann gehts wohl nicht mehr also
nicht mehr so gut versteht ja aber das
ding ist sie es auch noch mal wirklich
zwei köpfe kleiner erklären ja aber ich
kann mich trotzdem probleme aber so ist
schon schwierig das hat er mir wenn ich
versuche es noch mal so
jetzt machen wir dann rechts einzuhalten
[Musik]
einmal noch herr 22
trotz stark ja aber warum geht es jetzt
nicht mehr
ich bin sehr schwitzen das gibt es
ausnahmen hier soll ein hähnchen was man
so hoch hebt ich fühle mich wie jemand
der erst mal ein stück was verbraucher
warten einnahmen auch das ist glaube ich
der an strengste ich bin mal gespannt ob
ich das schaffe hier bis auf das ist ja
anstrengend weiß ich gar nicht
das weißt du machst und handstand und
ich nämlich dann schmeiße ich über mich
herein stark gemacht und nicht gepackt
am radlager kannst du das ist erst
versuchen dass ich dich beiwerk packen
kann
so wie machen wir die mama nachschlag
und ich versuche ja okay jetzt bauen
jetzt mache ich dieses john cena ich
möchte jetzt schmeißen
[Musik]
aber das sind alles extremsportler das
in extremsport ja ist doch so wer kann
denn sorgen wie soll ich dich schmeißen
und ich dann hinten aufwand du musst
dich wünschen wenn schon kein abo
abschließen kann
ich habe früher das rad gemacht hast
dann musst du dich so hinstellen so und
so machen und ich mache das was an
seinen beinen
[Musik]
deine beide sind direkte haben
geklatscht wie soll ich dich nicht so
recht daran
das wird gleich wieder weg leute leute
ich würde sagen das reicht erst mal in
sagen wir einen kleinen jack letzten
majors aufgeben ich weiß ihr könnt gerne
in die kommentare schreiben
auch wir zu schlecht sind oder ob ich zu
schwach bin oder ob noch nicht so schwer
wie es das ist gemein oder leite ich bin
177 im wege 60 kilogramm genau also
vielleicht wären wir sonst
verbesserungen ein bisschen leichter
wirst oder wenn du ein bisschen stärker
werden ja okay vielleicht auch einen ist
er am alex wie marie eingeblendet ja
genau
bis morgen übermorgen morgen ist
mittwochmorgen ist video feiertag und
abonniert allem einen zweiten kanal oder
main kanal ganz ganz bei instagram genau